hi guys just taking a stroll around the
hotel welcome to Friday Aires here's
what happened mistake this has been a
monumental experience huh
but um yeah it's weird relinquish that
control for someone else to edit it but
also it says it's by the script
you don't mean like on YouTube videos
you rip a lot and so a lot of it happens
in the editing which this film does as
well but we knew the story to expect so
that was less than or wracking I mean we
knew we weren't going to show up and
they were gonna cut it into a thriller
at least we hoped yeah thank you thank
you
this it is Saturday night and I just got
home because I did the monologue for ask
cat and I know that that's a weird
sentence for a lot of you but that
doesn't make any sense but ass cat is an
improv group that's founded by the four
founders of the UCB theatre and it's
been going for years and years and years
and they do a show or they have a
monologist come and they tell a story
and then they base their improv show off
of the story and I got asked to do it
tonight and as a person that has studied
improvident and brother this was a very
cool thing and I'm sorry I didn't film
any of it because they're just so cool
and I felt like a weirdo bring it like
right so I'm filming the aftermath of it
which is me being happy that I didn't
puke on stage telling stories yeah it
was very exciting at next clip food on
this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so posh then this happened
keeping my voice down so all the Polish
people who lasers don't think I'm a
total weirdo than this oh we just film
stuff at Mashable and it was so much fun
they are so sweet and I should have
filmed more but I'm an idiot and it's
raining gotta love New York City
it's mother nature is always crying when
she see her through sad thing and make
sure you go over and subscribe to their
five facts channel because that's the
video that we made and I think you guys
will really like it it was really fun
no I came to cut back on this happened
then this happened just it watch what
happens live this is the opposite look
how great everyone is doing a great job
it's not a base of it all then I did
this with this you guys are all in the
black that
[Music]
look I've [ __ ] dynamic this is when
I'm walking beautiful New York what
about this hmm debatable
alright well I am just in a full circle
and I am back to my room I don't forget
to go to camp Takota dot-com and you can
buy the song that we made with Flula for
the end credits of the movie the
original song camp it up on iTunes and
don't forget to come and buy tickets to
memory nice Boston show
there's not many tickets left so make
sure you grab them now and truly
they're my own
crédit instantly